record-breaking new numbers on the
coronavirus that take this crisis into
uncharted territory yesterday the u.s
added more than 150
000 daily cases for the first time
according to the coveted tracking
project
one in every 378 americans
tested positive for the virus in the
past week and in the past month the
number of people hospitalized with the
virus in the u.s
has nearly doubled doctors and nurses
are reporting shortages of essential
protective equipment
some hospitals are also running out of
beds and staff to treat covert patients
our lead national correspondent david
begno is at a testing site in suburban
chicago
as state and local leaders there
consider new restrictions david good
morning to you
simple question is chicago headed for a
new lockdown
well look we don't know that just yet
the mayor has declared a stay-at-home
advisory for now tony it doesn't have a
lot of teeth to it in terms of
enforcement
though the governor of illinois is
saying i may come back at you very soon
with a stay-at-home order here at the
testing site they've already lined up
they're going to open at 7am they've
been closing early because they're
running out of tests and a lot of labs
around this country are telling
testing sites hey listen don't go over
what we agreed to because we're going to
start getting backed up
and we may have delays in testing like
we had earlier on in the pandemic
i mentioned the governor of illinois
it's really the governors that are
stepping up to the plate right now
especially here in the midwest
a lot of them are saying when i come
back to you you're not going to like
what i have to say
with cases and hospitalizations rising
chicago is telling its residents
to stay inside do not have guests over
avoid unnecessary travel and cancel
your traditional thanksgiving plans dr
benjamin singer at northwestern memorial
hospital
says the number of covet
hospitalizations in chicago
is fast approaching levels they haven't
seen since the worst
days back in april the pandemic is real
it's deadly and we need strong
cooperation within our communities
chicago the nation's third largest city
is among the first to announce a
stay-at-home advisory and it probably
won't be the last
in states across america governors from
both parties
are sounding the alarm given the silence
from the white house
listen to what they're saying the curve
that we had flattened
right now this curve is a straight line
and it is
straight up we can't keep expecting the
hospitals to meet the demand
we're running out of time and we're
running out of options
limit your social gatherings to just
those
of your immediate household to the west
now california is the second state to
record more than one
million coronavirus cases in utah
all of that state's staffed icu beds are
now full
so the governor has called nearly 200
traveling nurses
and in north dakota they have just nine
icu beds left
statewide one in every 83 residents
tested positive this week the system is
so strained
that the state's republican governor
issued an order
clearing nurses who are infected with
the virus
to continue working with covet patients
as long as those nurses are asymptomatic
but the nurses association says they're
asking the governor to implement a mask
mandate first but he just won't do it
and the numbers are just much much worse
than we've ever seen before that's dr
ashi
shah dean at brown university's school
of public health he says with vaccines
on the horizon
there is an end to this pandemic and
it's in sight
but the worst is far from over for us i
understand the fatigue but people really
do have to pull it together
we're not talking about forever we're
just saying for the next couple of
months those are the critical ones
we hear you doctor loud and clear you
know he told us at the end of that
interview
that california and new york for the
most part are keeping things under
control and he pointed to them
as models for other states to follow as
we continue on in this pandemic
gail david thank you